AND WACKAUGHTER'Y HEIR LOVED O
HIS FAMILYGPS  O NO E
ASSUS A SAOUTE BEC
OF THE DTI IE  FWSUIT CLAIMS GOR
E BRIDFAILED TDA M
IMP IS PAXTOFAOUR GOAT
LAWSUIT.E FAMING ENY ALPHABET
AND ILG E GEKEMMCOENAS
ALTO, R PAID
BUT YOUR HUSBA WAS
ARBIAY P
WHATID THINKHEDIDN?D YOU TELLOU
ELIRST TH WHEN I
WOKE DIDN'ALLYE , SAW HEKIND O.
MY DAUGHTER CAME DASKE
AND , I .STNO, IT'S OKAY,W HE DE
TRUCD THEN I KIND OF
BACK ROOM D STARTED CALLIN
AND ASKING WHET AND THE' D T
OANYTHING.LL POLICE.
S ON TITS ARHERE.N HECKED TH
JUSTSHE TOLD
WE.ANAL MY FRIENDS AND JUST
THE LOOKN THEI K
EL FT THEYTELLING AT-
WHERE ISD SOHE
OF M.
THENT 000 , OFOWN.
GIS DOSEE IF
H
SOG ITY.
K .Y SAID
NO, YOURENT AND
AVEN WITH D S SORT OF IN
THSTEROS HIM, BUE  VY D JUSTNNI
COUNTERTOPS.UNDEI  DHUWAE GOINGD
NO . IT' HARD.
A I HADO
OS HOO
NG, I
N'T IMAGINE AS WEL
ZOU
DE FOR THA
HE, DO YOU HANO ATTENT WHYCALLY
E ROAD. TS OU FOUR RWE ARELY TW
DECADES AGO.D WHEN THEY BUILTH
DEVELOPMENT, TY
BUT THEIR RESIER TUR TO E NORTH.
DID NEITHER.
AND THIS WASATIN THE CNITO
KE RESPONSIBILITY
WITH RESPECTGOOGLE,
THERE WAS ESSEIAD
DLE OF A
MULTIPLE CNTS WERE MADE TOAND WA
E PSTELLINEMT
THIS TELLING TE ARTICLES
SHOWED TT THIS BRIDGE WAS OUT
OUW GIT OFLIIOUSLY IS R PAYOIS I
S OTHER ANGPS.ANSO USE IT,KI OCA
LL BE N'DRE
Y ABOU BLL
HAVE TO USE  THE
ATO  OF  THE THING Y TRUSTS IT.S